ربما كان من الممكن ان تصبح مدرسه رياضيات
او ان تبقى مطوله برامج حاسوب لكن جدد
فورت نار اختارت طريقا اخر جعلها ثاني
اغنى سيده عصاميه في امريكا مع ثروه تزيد
على سبعه مليارات دولار فما سر هذه الثروه
ولدت او جودي فورتنر عام
1943 لوالدين يعملان بالقطاع الصحي ما
جعلها مهتمه بهذا المجال رغم انها حصلت
على بكالوريوس الرياضيات من كليه
الديكنسون في بنسلفانيا حيث نشات قبل ان
تنتقل الى ولايه ويسكنسون وتلتحق بجامعه
ماديسون للحصول على الماجستير في علوم
الكمبيوتر خلال دراساتها العليا تم تكليف
فولكنر ببناء وترميز نظام حفظ السجلات
لقسم الطب النفسي بالجامعه لكنها قادت
تصميم انظمه السجلات السريريه لجميع اقسام
المستشفى بعد ذلك التقت جو مع نحو عشره
مبرمجين اخرين ومديري المعلومات في
الجامعه والمؤسسات الاخرى لبدء مشروع في
تسويق انظمه السجلات الطبيه فجمعوا حوالي
70 الف دولار في عام
1979 لتاسيس شركه هيومان سيرفس كمبيوتر
التي اصبحت لاحقا ايبك سيستمز كانت حصه
منها سته الاف دولار جزء منها حصلت عليه
من والديها اصبحت الشركه تنمو بشكل متسارع
فمع بدايه الالفيه وبقياده جدث بلغت
المبيعات 50 مليون دولار فيما اصبح لديها
500 موظفا واعتبرت افضل بائع شامل
لتكنولوجيا معلومات الرعايه الصحيه في عام
2009 تم تعيين فورت نار من قبل الرئيس
باراك اوباما بلجنه سياسه تكنولوجيا
المعلومات الصحيه حيث عملت فيها حتى عام
وصنفتها فورس كاقوى امراه في مجال الرعايه
الصح في عام 2013 وحصلت لاحقا على العديد
من التكريمات لمجهودها في تنظيم عمل
مؤسسات الرعايه الصحيه خلال خمسه وعشرين
عاما اصبحت
تخدم اكبر المستشفيات وانظمه الرعايه
الصحيه مثل جونز هوبكنز وميو كلينك ما
جعلها ايضا تدر ايرادات مرتفعه حيث قدرت
مبيعاتها عام 2021 بنحو ثلاثه مليارات
و800 مليون دولار اما جدد فورت نار فلم
تعد مجرد مبرمجه للحاسوب فهي اليوم الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه التي تمتلك 47% منها
ومليارديره مع ثروه تقدر بسبعه مليارات
ومئه مليون دولار جمعتها بعصاميه
[موسيقى]